[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera
eccomi in terza serata come certi film
su telecapri era il sogno della mia vita
e finalmente l'ho realizzato e ci sta
con il nostro talk che si chiama
censurate quel capezzolo questo sono io
il terribile foto i miei contatti
il mio disco sul sesso da ragazzina sono
fatte pochissime breve battute in cui
sommariamente i miei genitori un po
imbarazzati mi hanno detto di non fare
la scema e di non rimanere incinta
quello che ne è conseguito è che io sono
state errori data per anni dal controllo
delle nascite ma non ho mai avuto paura
delle malattie sessualmente
trasmissibili
ma la cosa più forte che in un certo
senso avesse la tua è quel discorso così
breve era che in qualche modo io fossi
responsabile delle azioni e dei giudizi
degli altri
contemporaneamente il mio fratello e
veniva in qualche modo redarguito perché
aveva preso questa abitudine di dormire
circondato dalle mie barbie ci riempiva
tutto il letto solo qualche mese dopo si
è scoperto che mio fratello realizzava
diciamo una fantasia della ram quindi
l'universo etero normato era salvo ed
era stato beccato il figlio arcobaleno
sbagliato il sesso è veramente ovunque
ovunque
paradossalmente non ne parliamo mai e
per parlare non intendo accennare
ridacchiare guardarsi un film porno di
nascosto parlo proprio di condividere le
paure i desideri le cose che ci
piacciono ma anche dell'informazione per
esempio quello che dicevo prima sulle
malattie sessualmente trasmissibili che
una cosa che non mi ha mai toccato in
tutta per lunga parte della mia vita
perché non ne parliamo mai di questa
cosa
una cosa più se la si nasconde non solo
diventa in qualche modo proibita il che
per il sesso diciamoci la verità non è
un problema
ma il vero problema è che quando non
parliamo di qualcosa
quella cosa viene ignorata nel senso che
genera ignoranza non sappiamo cosa ci
piace
non sappiamo cosa piace all'altra
persona conquistiamo non riusciamo a
informarci non parliamo non solo di
prevenzione per esempio al tumore al
seno
anche quello è parlare del nostro corpo
della nostra sessualità parlare delle
malattie e può portare a conseguenze nel
caso dei corpi e del sino a cose molto
gravi come la sieropositività
ma anche la depressione anche disturbi
alimentari anche quelli fanno parte del
nostro corpo i dogmi che abbiamo nel
parlare anche tra amici di queste di
questo genere di cose
ora facciamo un gioco un gioco legato al
sesso visto l'orario e funziona così io
vi faccio delle domande
e voi se dovete rispondere sia alzate la
mano altrimenti lasciate la mano passata
io saprò chi sta mentendo ma non lo dirò
nessuno e come in tutti i giochi
diciamo legate all'erotico ma in
generale questo è un safe place cioè nel
senso è un luogo sicuro tutto quello che
di rete o ammetterete rimarrà
all'interno di questa sfera rossa
intorno a me non potrà essere usato
contro di voi
e il bello dell'orario e del gioco e che
se va male magari trovate qualcuno con
cui tornare a casa
la prima domanda quindi si si alza la
mano altrimenti mano abbassata
parlate con il vostro partner di tutte
le fantasie sessuali che avete anche in
generale non per forza con lui lei delle
vostre paure dei vostri timori
ok stata la mano
seconda domanda quanti di voi negli
ultimi sono buone gli ultimi due anni
hanno fatto controlli su malattie
sessualmente trasmissibili
adesso una domanda prima per gli uomini
e poi per le donne
quanti di voi hanno raggiunto l'orgasmo
nell'ultimo rapporto sessuale
ok e le donne allora questa è la slide
dell'ansia dell'una di sera
allora questo è uno studio molto
importante che rileva che i casi di
sifilide sono aumentati del 70 per cento
nel 2015 e di clamidia del 100 per cento
dal 2010 c'è un altro dato che non è
presente in questa slide e cioè il
numero dei sieropositivi in italia che
ha aumentato esponenzialmente
soprattutto per gli under 25
com'è possibile viviamo nell'era
dell'informazione e ovunque è possibile
reperire delle informazioni
eppure stiamo regredendo siamo meno
informati di prima in qualche modo c'è
un altro studio molto divertente e lo
studio più grande compiuto sulla
sessualità viene stato preso questo
campione è molto grande di uomini e
donne in è stato chiesto chi di loro nel
completo anonimato quindi senza avere
gioco il fidanzato la fidanzata proprio
fianco che avesse raggiunto l'orgasmo
nell'ultimo rapporto gli uomini quando
ha risposto sì per il 91 per cento e le
donne per il 39 per cento
questo è un dato che ci dice molto mi ha
molto colpito la prima volta che l'ho
visto perché le donne non richiedono
l'orgasmo perché approfondendo questo
studio c'è un altro dato e cioè che
l'ottanta per cento di queste donne
dello studio erano eterosessuali che può
voler dire niente e il 99 per cento di
queste stesse donne di cui solamente il
40 per cento hanno raggiunto l'orgasmo
raggiungono stereo
l'orgasmo da sole con la stimolazione
clitoridea quindi è chiaro che non c'è
un problema fisico non c'è un blocco
magari psicologico su questo per una
brevissima parentesi ci sono molti casi
donne anorgasmia che non è una cosa
fisica ma è un blocco psicologico
quindi cos'è che blocca le donne dal
chiedere al proprio uomo la propria
donna
in questo caso l'uomo di aiutarli a
raggiungere l'orgasmo di stimolare
procuratori des e quello che insomma le
aiuta cos'è che ci blocca in una cosa
così intima e così la più grande cose di
condivisione che possiamo fare con un
altro essere umano se in quel momento
non siamo sinceri con l'altro di quello
che ci piace o non ci piace io non so
quando possiamo esserlo questa
ossessione per la censura del sesso e
dei corpi noi la stiamo via via
trasportando anche il digitale con
grande successo
gli algoritmi le linee guida delle
community per esempio non voglio parlare
in esteso di quello sulla nudità
mi soffermo solamente sul capezzolo
perché voglio dire perché censurare un
capezzolo femminile
ok l'atto sessuale posso capirlo con
sforzo perché ci sono secondo me e altri
metodi per per arginare diciamo oltre
una pornografia però il capezzolo
femminile con capi non lo capisco c'è il
capezzolo maschile non è censurato
perché il capezzolo femminile ricondotto
alla nudità o atto pornografico
in che modo questo è un atto
pornografico quand'è che la
consapevolezza del nostro corpo ci ha
fatto scivolare così in basso
linee guida dei social network ci dicono
che questo avviene per tutelare la
quiete dell'utente un utente che però
non è turbato in nessun modo da discorsi
dell'odio fascismo immagini di violenza
su quest'ultima vi potrete dire
effettivamente guardate anche le
immagini di violenza sono però segnalate
dall'algoritmo è vero
ultimamente però c'è stata una revisione
di queste linee guida e facebook quindi
anche east che ama dice che le immagini
di violenza sono consentite
qualora queste
aumentino in qualche modo la
consapevolezza del gesto di violenza
nell'utente il capezzolo non aumenta la
consapevolezza dell'utente del corpo un
corpo che abbiamo tutti la senso che
penso che ce l'abbiamo tutti in che modo
può essere turbato un tredicenne alla
vista di un capezzolo
anche perché questo si ricongiungono dei
fatti che io trovo molto gravi
personalmente come per esempio lo
scandalo legato alla censura della foto
io non voglio manco parlare dell'origine
della vita del quadro che è stato
censurato ma di olivia wilde che allatta
al seno la figlia sulla copertina di
glamour questa cosa questa rimozione non
è solo una questione online noi quando
facciamo questo e quindi ritorniamo a
quei dati sulla clamidia e quant'altro
stiamo insegnando alle nuove generazioni
che il capezzolo femminile
l'allattamento è qualcosa di cui
vergognarsi è qualcosa che non può
essere mostrato pubblicamente
quante donne vedete che allattano i
luoghi pubblici
io molto poche eppure ho scoperto con le
mie amiche perché io non sono madre che
quando nasce un bambino lo deve lottare
ogni due ore come fanno queste donne a
muoversi nello spazio pubblico e non
allattare costruiscono delle piccole
scatole io l'ho visto una cosa in cui
tantissima piccole scatole al cui
interno queste donne possono allattare
senza finestra senza nulla senza
immagini nei centri commerciali nei
luoghi perché una donna si deve
nascondere per allattare un figlio
secondo me c'è c'è un problema molto
grave di rimozione nel nostro corpo
questo questo tema delle immagini di
nudo è anche legato a qualcos'altro non
sono solo le immagini che vengono che
vengono rimosse i nostri corpi ci sono
anche delle parole illecite che sui
social noi non possiamo dire non
possiamo scrivere e voi penserete a
chissà quali immagini pornografiche
esistono una lista di hashtag potremmo
dire bannati che sono qui i responsabili
di quello che comunemente viene definito
shadow ban cioè viene oscurato l'asta
che dalla lista degli austriache
ufficiali o comunque c'è meno visibilità
dal partner algoritmo tra questi hashtag
cioè l'astag furbi curvi e la sua
identità
le immagini dei corpi diciamo più site
in questo nicki minaj ha fatto una
battaglia molto grande e incredibile noi
quindi con censuriamo i capezzoli
c'entriamo tutta una serie di cose
addirittura i corpi plus size io
qual è la ragione si versa accaniscono
molti profili vengono cancellati di
modelle che fanno questo genere di cose
questa questione della censura della
rimozione sistematica però non è una
questione solamente quindi di immagini
parole ma lo diventiamo anche
nell'esporre le parole come nel caso di
elisa pò marelli in cui le testate di
pensiero di destra hanno definito il suo
assassino un gigante buono e le testate
di pensiero di sinistra hanno insinuato
che forse questo uomo era arrabbiato
perché lei era lesbica ma si era
scoperto lesbica solo in una seconda
parte della sua vita
quindi come siamo arrivati a qui a
questa rimozione sistematica dei nostri
corpi a non parlare a non avere orgasmi
a censura dei capezzoli a esporre i
nostri giovani alle malattie sessuali
come siamo arrivati fin qui non
parlandone adesso io ci ho riflettuto e
ho provato a dare una delle delle
proposte libera su cui potete anche
intervenire
la prima è quella di praticare insieme
degli atti di ribellione come è il gioco
di prima
l'atto principali ribellione e parlare
tra di noi ok noi non siamo dei grandi
decisori pubblici dell'hobby stino che
non possiamo prendere deciso dall'alto
però possiamo rivoluzionare la nostra
vita possiamo avere il 100 per cento e
gli orgasmi che è una cosa pazzesca che
ci pensi queste sono delle piccole
regole
la prima è quella di non giudicare gli
altri che è difficilissima e molto
difficile mi rendo conto noi stessi
ancora più difficile e gli altri corpi
degli altri cosa fanno gli altri non ci
ossessionano su queste cose non sono
rilevanti
parliamo di sesso sempre che la cosa più
divertente che cioè di cui possiamo
parlare non per bassa religione politica
parliamo di sesso con gli amici che a me
colpisce sempre questo esperimento
parlando con gli amici uomini e loro
fanno una cosa incredibile davvero un
sacco per questi per questo fatto da
ragazzini gli uomini non sono molto
piccole inizio non scoprire il proprio
corpo e ogni tanto diciamo si uniscono
insieme a causa di qualche amico e si
mostrano il pene è una cosa di gragnola
ammiro moltissimo questa fase della loro
della loro vita perché segno di grande
consapevolezza del proprio corpo e anche
di orgoglio ma che bello cioè tutti in
una donna una cosa del genere la farebbe
mai una cosa che non farebbe marinisti
con gli amici e per guardarsi in semi
genitali senso che ci penso io da
piccolo volevo fare le cose con le mie
amiche finire l'imbarazzo
paradossalmente non lo facciamo magari
con l'amichetto uomo non lo facciamo con
le con le bambine che dovrebbero essere
diciamo la nostra adwords
questa cosa ci insegna molto parlare con
gli amici per diciamo al partner cosa ci
piace e cosa non ci piace
affrontiamo anche dei temi impegnativi
perché no comunque parliamo delle nostre
paure perché poi alla fine sono le paure
di tutti non è che sono solo nostre
cioè l'uomo fa la tecnologia si evolve
loro sesso lo facciamo da un sacco di
tempo quindi più o meno diciamo i
problemi li abbiamo scoperti un po tutti
per diciamo fare qualcosa in prima
persona ho fondato un associazione al
tema così ma chiamiamolo un collettivo
che si chiama amore che tratta di parità
di genere ed argomenti lgbt
chiunque può proporre degli argomenti da
scrivere oppure proporre degli eventi
perché ci sono circa 80 volontari tra
cui altri profili anche nella
comunicazione e quindi qualsiasi evento
dalla sessualità a qualsiasi altro
argomento che sia inclusivo può essere
ospitato all'interno diciamo di morti un
hub e adesso come ultimo esperimento
questo un esperimento il mio personale
ho provato a scrivere il discorso sul
sesso che avrei fatto alla mia bambina
carisa bella non mi conosci ma sono late
adulta so che sei confusa e chi ha paura
hai ragione adesso ti fanno sentire
insicura e colpevolizzata perfino che ti
ama
non voglio mentire chi non lo farei mai
sarà dura strumentalizzerà nel tuo corpo
lo denigra danno e lo useranno le tue
amiche non vorranno parlare di
masturbazione
molte di loro non si masturbano se
vorrei parlare di alcuni argomenti
verrai tacciata di essere una poco di
buono mentre intanto utilizzare
contraccettivi sarà visto come una cosa
scomoda cercheranno di ridurre tuo
fratello a discorsi sulla dimensione del
pene e lo schiacci erano in standard
dimas qualità tossici indicheranno la
tenerezza
l'affezione e il piacere dell'altro lui
non è un nemico è un alleato dovrei fare
attenzione a come ti vesti
come ti muovi ti giudicheranno in base a
quello
tu sii forte e non di pensare e non
seguire il loro esempio ti prego tu non
dare giudizi
impara masturbarti bene prima di avere
rapporti sessuali amati regolarmente sia
attenta alla tua igiene e alla cura
della tua persona
ricordati che tutto deve essere fatto
con gioia e con senso che non esiste un
modo giusto in cui si gode e si persegue
la felicità ai un corpo bellissimo e
diventarne fiera persegue il bello e
cerca di vederlo in tutte le sue forme
parla parla parla
non tanto per parlare ma per condividere
parlare per chiedere non vergognarti mai
di chi sei e di chi ami qualche volta ne
soffrì rai ma la tua serenità può
donarne anche a chi ti giudica sono solo
spaventarsi a c'è un'ultima cosa
so che quello che sto per dirti è ancora
più difficile ma abbiamo poco tempo e
c'è bisogno che sia concisa
un giorno dovrebbe tenere uno speech
davanti a tante persone parlerà di tutto
questo dovrai sporty avrei paura e ci
ripenserà in mille volte forse non
servirà a niente sporty così tanto su
temi così delicati ma forse anche solo
per una persona che ti ascolta può fare
la differenza
devi farlo per lei non è nulla di così
mera andrà tutto bene
[Applauso]
[Musica]